so one of the things on my wish list for
this year is a big honking telescope
from what I understand most of them use
mirrors to reflect light now this guy's
a little different what's the story with
this yeah this is the explore scientific
is an eight-millimeter a pro chromatic
telescope and what it uses to focus in
on distant objects is a series of lenses
but the problem with most telescopes
that uses lenses like that is that you
get a lot of interference with with
colors and with detail so what this guy
does is that it focuses in on the three
primary colors so red yellow blue and
what that does is it gives you much true
colors and better detail on things but
how expensive is it uh so if these are a
but it looks pretty print over that's
that's actually not that unreason see
the the telescope's you're talking about
before the ones that use mirrors are way
more expensive they run thousands of
dollars just wants only 800 bucks so if
you share an amateur astronomer or
somebody who wanted to like get into
astronomy this is actually a really good
way to go it's actually great too
because it has this mount on it that
lets you put onto any type odd so say
you have entered Mathis it's a stay at a
tripod mount so yeah so if you have a
tripod or you know dick us a box up one
exactly you can just throw it on that
and you're good to go now it also comes
with a small hard case and what you can
do is you can break down all the pieces
put it in the case lock it up and travel
around with it and it doesn't matter if
you knock it around because you're not
going to get a cracked lens yeah I mean
really there's really nothing worse than
a cracklins well except for maybe like a
stolen lens yeah where do you think I
got this this even on my wish list this
year I want something that will really
upgrade my stereo equipment I want
something that will deliver like better
sound but also kind of looks cool it's
not like a nondescript black box what
have you got for me well what you just
described is exactly this which is
niehaus laboratories t2 amplifier now
it's a vacuum tube amp
it has a stainless steel body it has
gold inputs in the back which cuts down
on all the residents things like that so
there's less buzzing when digital and
analog signals go through also there's
like a less popular hissing yeah much
more popping and locking alright so what
else is cool about this thing is that in
the back it's got a USB port and it's
fitted optical cord well slow down there
Thomas Alva Edison tell me what what
does that allow me to do so what you can
do is you can take your computer and you
can pump digital files direct into this
guy oh that's really cool and so you
skip the sound card in your computer
which normally takes a digital file and
condenses it down to then spit it into
an analog signal to put through your
speakers so Stephen these daqing to till
the front here they decorated for they
actually have a function no absolutely
so the problem with digital music in
general and everyone complains about is
that you lose a lot of these sort of
subtleties and intricacies yes I was
cold exactly so what these do is they
add a little bit of warmth and texture
to the music that you normally only get
with an analog signal that's really cool
so how much is this guy 795 dollars whoa
that's kind of a lot you think it's
worth it absolutely despite being a
vacuum this thing does not suck
you